hi I'm Ryan I'm cat and I'm Jerry we're
gonna be watching the trailer for the DC
comic film son of Batman yeah man it's
about Batman son joining a motorcycle
gang yeah I've seen some of these DC
comic films I really liked Batman year
one I really like The Dark Knight
Returns have you guys seen those no no
it's okay I'm the coolest I'm not cool
this one and the groove yeah I have DC
Comics in my house yeah yeah yeah and
I've seen the Dark Knight trilogy so you
know that counts for something anyway
we're gonna watch this trailer you're
gonna watch us react interesting all
right guys let's get our Batman on let's
do it
it's as a company in this future now
Julia do you want
[Music]
reservations Rachele pool has been
retired you may call me Deathstroke she
thinks you'd be better off with me
are you fine by myself I love it looks
like out of it yeah yeah we don't kill
me don't kill it's gone to be informed -
yeah I have your mother Damien's got
your accident
and this really cool Jesus but you'll
play Damien I got chills I got chills
Jerry feels good stuff good stuff that
looks cool it doesn't look as good as
the other DC car films I've seen but I
think overall would be a pretty JIT
movie I want to see it yeah I want to
see it Batman as a single dad you know
yeah Batman is a single dad raising a
kid I mean bills are probably easy to
pay though I wonder if he's there for
his sitcom actually that could be a son
Bruce Wayne and his kid
don't focus on Batman at all he's just
just Bruce Wayne and his son know that
I've been Wayne Manor though the only
part Batman show up in is like when
Bruce is reading the morning paper and
someone will comment on a Batman story
than the audience will laughs yeah